ne touchez à rien pourtant c'est le nom
du jeu et là c'est le remake 3d voilà il
est tout beau tout lisse tout propre
c'est parti on va tous touchés ah ouais
tu me dites pas faire un truc j'ai envie
de le faire 2 ou flûte on se cherchait
donc on est là il ya ce [ __ ] de
panneaux devant nous au quai pendant que
le mec se douche et on sait pas où on
est on sait pas ce cadeau qu'un bouton
va toucher le bouton ça use ça oh merde
j'absorbe autour du cou à il ya d'autres
cas apparaissent trois deux un
au verger caché une bombe nucléaire bac
s est vu comme un état de choc
pendant ce temps là la haye love
mushrooms moi j'aimais jo c'est mon
ventre ça dans une chaise dg de carreaux
gris je m'inquiétais gérard depardieu
qu'est ce que je fais avec sa as
je colle sur le mur dacor ac la première
fois je suppose ah ouais ça recommence
il ya plusieurs fins d'accord c'est ça
et le but ça va être de troupes [ __ ]
mais il ya tout ça comme format sans
déconner à ce qu'un moyen de pas tout
faire péter george juste appuyé sur
reset les daft punk mais qu'ils vont
commencer comme ça alors me juge pas je
te plaît à bas du coup j'ai plus du tout
envie d'appuyer ce bouton je veux
vraiment pas tuer des gens avec une
bombe nucléaire
mais je crois que oui car tout à fait en
vrai ah si un livre l'a8 2,67 égale des
8067 on retient ça je peux pas ouvrir
layar joystick je peux va le prendre et
l'imprimante pas c'est un prime des
choses correctes
ok donc surpris dans le bon sens a fait
en bas à gauche en haut à gauche
or à gauche en bas à gauche battant
c'était un truc afin que le joystick ya
juste là justement bassin tampon ce parc
touristique
lucas arts est cette addiction aux jeux
vidéo bon mec jazeera m'ont obligée non
mais ya pas trop de solution
si j'ai appuyé au cij rapide dessus au
lieu d'être déclenchées celui-là ça fait
ça un + 2/3 de +35 ya pas de cinq
cabanons 3 1 2 2 à 1 c'est ça 3 1 2 2 1
mais non mais c'est marc ela arrêter de
mentir aussi et ya une flèche là j'avais
pas vu regardez j'ai recommencé il ya
les sept flèches que je n'avais pas vu
ah non mais y avait un truc à faire
c'était une autre énigme au bon c'est
pas bon ces ouvertures avec un tournevis
qui surfe avec ce tour de vis mon gars
il ya un truc à dévisser grippe part à
l'ag dégustha [ __ ] voilà j'aime bien
prospecteurs squeeze le mec fait
notamment des expériences sur les
hamsters à mi temps c'est normal dans ce
bureau on aura besoin du tournevis assis
là pour dévisser sa ba oui mais pas des
hamsters maintenant non quatre boutons
c'est par rapport avec ses couleurs là à
temps il ya vert rouge bleu jaune mec
c'est sûr c'est ça non aussi pourquoi ça
veut dire quoi ça ok à gauche et un marc
sauer mars pour enfoncer un truc ça
l'écran mais faut pas faire ça que les
télévisions oui ça ça arrive que quand
tu l'as acheté wiimote sofa exprime ce
que tu as un blaireau
[Musique]
et ben voilà la deuxième fin la fois
illuminati c'est bien ça c'était offrir
cette ambiance était très pesante bon
mois mec je suis attiré par salah par
ses flèches là le blabla c'est que si je
touche autre chose ça va le leur a tiré
peut-être faire ça tu sais c'est là le
sait tous qu'il y avait des plages
correct bas gauche badr watch pas quoi
mais on n'a qu'une flèche donc je pense
qu'il ya d'autres cas faire pour faire
apparaître d'autres flèches en fait je
pense un bois sur bois les choses dans
leurs décisions ne seraient pas de
résoudre l'énigme du 1 2 3 cas là c'est
une combinaison de combien de chiffres
six chiffres ce qui fait 6 x 6 x 6 x 6 x
6 x 6 combinaison voilà on va pas se
faire chier à taper 46 me combinaisons
possibles au mordant mais voilà un +121
plus de 3,3 moins de 1,1 +23 anna tarder
moi je pense que nos plus grandes
possibilités d'arriver à quelque chose
là c'est le tout des couleurs parce que
quatre chefs du truc à remplir donc ça
fait 4 x 4 x 4 x 4 possibles nombre de
possibilités donc c'est moins élevé que
6 x 6 x 6 x 6 c'est super chaud ok donc
là je sais pas moi bleu rouge rouge
jaune vert bleu bleu rouge vert vers
vers le bleu bleu
rouge bleu vert vert vert rouge bleu
bleu vert rouge rose jaune jaune rouge
bleu rouge aux chiens parce qu'il a fait
j'y croyais et même page
bref moi je me faire ça pendant une
heure ça m'amusait de ouf après je me
dis est ce que j'aimerais retrouver une
combinaison ou alors c'est parce que
j'ai eus faut trop de fois qu'il ya ça
qui s'est passé je sais pas tout n'est
que sorcellerie et complot non je pense
vraiment que ça c'est quand je me faire
trop de fois voilà donc du coup je me
suis calé pour rien et si avec le
marteau je pète cette merde de fuck
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce bébé en chocolat mais 21
sorcellerie weeds eu des morts elle mais
qui va sortir de sa douche
il va halluciné ben quoi j'me suis pro
offre de tourisme de stickers à menacer
un bébé en chocolat mais qui a paru il
se cache et un temps pour tout si tu es
mort il est mort puis personne ne pourra
jamais dans cette bombe nucléaire
c'est la fin et ben laisser la fin et
ben voilà une fois en plus beaux
questions à faire bon moi je vais
trouver la fin avec les chiffres
salah mais c'est sûr ces salles à troyes
1 2 2 1 1
[Musique]
merde j'ai ptet que tu es en bas du dos
it alors déjà déjà tu veux ou tu veux
descendre parce qu'un jour un grand sage
a dit oui c'est la raison alors mais qu
eux
voilà voilà voilà voilà je pense que ça
fait un valide pas terme bages mumbai
couche ça c'est quoi c'est un levier et
bam boum mon pote oh [ __ ] t'as il a
tous à son contrôle deux mais c'est quoi
ce sont très exactement ce match haut en
bas c'est faire un casse tête chinois
grandeur réelle et faire jouer ton pote
que tu as touché alors que juste pété le
cerveau c'est ça ton travail
bon du coup il ya 300 00 ou alors 8 2 6
7 s'est de trucs que je vois clairement
c'est un code à quatre chiffres ça
existe ça 3 sets à 0
non lui 2,6 mais savait qu on appelle
mad et on lui demande de faire un mix à
ce moment là s'ils connaissent assez
japy tuche sûr ça fait un bruit batterie
voilà c'est faux c'est du montage
benjamin lagarde youtube le mec il est
trop chaud il dit donc là avec solange
pad aussi milliards de combinaisons
possibles ou à faire l'étoile satanique
que ya sur le tableau de 14 c'est quoi
c'est çà çà çà
oh c'est quoi ce délire mon gars après
on part vraiment sur install délire là
un sale délire mon gars y'a du sort qui
coule des murs leur passe plus vite
est-ce qu'on a un papier oui on a un
papier nouvelle forme j'aimerais trouver
la faim qui avec ce papier là avec la
combinaison j'aimerais trouver mais je
pense que c'est vraiment sa part sur
salat cette petite flèche mais que c'est
sûr attente on a fait tout à l'heure
c'était pas 3 2 1 1 2 3 non attends
c'était 3-1 2-2 1-3 voilà peut-être mais
qu'en fait ça c'est bon ça je sais pas
trop mais non [ __ ] le con je me dis
peut-être que ça en fait c'est ça hein
dis que ça donc dans le bon sens et bas
gauche aux gauchos gauche bas gauche oh
oui ça marche qui se passe ça nous est
faux
ou de fuck c'est la fin ufo les gens
hurlent washington - bat les couilles a
bâti sa vas toi
reset est ce qu'on a un papier oui le
papier ufo il est quoi ce jeu il ya
trente [ __ ] de fin à mon gars vous
rendez compte c'est énorme et que le
nombre de trucs qu'on peut faire qu'un
niveau des possibilités c'est ouf on a
de quoi tu fais rien pendant 3 minutes
ou cinq minutes où je sais pas combien
de temps il y c'est bon t'as gagné une
fin la fin à a
maître zen qui n'a réussi à rien touché
peu mec parfait voilà rien sauf si je
suis pas resté là pour 4 pt 1 foot
j'étais en train de tuer pour voir s'il
ya des fins de rôle
voilà je maintiens vidéo sur plus d'une
tonne génétique j'espère que ça vous a
fait vous n'avez rien toucher ce nom
c'est la fessée mon pote n'hésitez pas
là mais ça vous a plu mais c'est trop
marrant ce jeu qui est 30 fin possible
et que le but c'est de trouver soi-même
les 30 fin possible but qui est
quasiment impossible
c'est vrai bah écoutez je vous mets au
défi de le faire sans regarder la vidéo
du mais comme j'étais en train de faire
honteusement danger belge l'énigme herbe
quand je fais une vidéo là franchement
vous retrouvez pourront trouver plus de
10 je pense qu'il peut jouer au moins
1h30 2h mais vraiment et encore faut
être doué quoi là on parle de squeeze on
parle pas de 1 me mais qu'elle retrouva
il est content assez homogène cela se
regarde et portez vous bien tu prouves
pis ouais je tente un truc way
[Musique]